hello everyone my tooth is still killing
me so I'll definitely go for a nice
craft beer or two after I make this
video and that being said welcome to the
final round of the 2013 candidates
tournament we're gonna kick it off with
Magnus Carlsen versus Peter Svidler now
as you've seen in my previous video
these are the standings after the
penultimate round it's crossing and
crumbling battling it out both 8 and a
half points and sweedler even if he wins
this game well he can have eight points
but he can never win the candidates
tournament
so it's either Carlsen or kramnik and
for the final game Carlsen could not be
in a better position so if Carson and
kramnik finish the game with the same
number of points like if they both draw
their games they both have nine points
Carson will win because he has a better
additional criteria and he does have the
white pieces against Peter Svidler he
already defeated Peter Svidler in this
tournament with the black pieces so
definitely he could not be in a better
situation so before we check out the
game we do have some photos of this
round here as usual a bunch of
photographers a photographer
photographing Magnus Carlsen before the
game here we have a nice game of Peter
Svidler he is ready for war as you can
see also a nice close-up of Magnus
Carlsen checking out swindler you know
for for any weaknesses and here we have
also a nice photo stealer and Coulson
you can see that Coulson is pretty
stressed out or who knows what he's
doing but you know it's the stress is
real he has to he has to at least draw
listen him he cannot allow a loss in
this game and he's playing against the
Peter Svidler who defeated vastly von
Schuch and vastly von Schuch is the only
player who defeated Magnus Carlsen in
this tournament so let's see this game
so far
Carlson has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 so the
real opus just a second there okay so
Bishop to b5 drew Lopez and a6 more fees
defense
Bishop to a4 Knight to f6 we have
castles Bishop to e7
d3 b5 now Bishop to b3 b6 pretty
standard a three-wheeler castles Knight
to c3 and the bishop to b7 Bishop to d2
we have Queen to d7 and a4 now trying to
break open here on the Queen side and
here you can go something like nice to
a5 after Bishop way to go see five but
fiddler goes for a different idea he
goes Knights to d8 which is somewhat
different but but also very nice we have
a key after some b5 a cap for some b5
rook captures an a8 Bishop captures and
now nice to e2 preparing to bring the
knight over 2g 3 where the night will
have some nice squares like f5 and h5
and if black wants to stop this he will
have to weaken his Kings position with
the g6 so night to e6 that's a very nice
square for the knight occupying maybe
occupying f4 in the future d4 will be
maybe available and if white wants to
get rid of the strong night you will
have to give up the bishop pair so night
to g3 c5 now expanding as expected
Knight comes to f5 we have Bishop to d8
and not allowing night to capture the
bishop and now c4 b captures on c4
Bishop captures on c4 and Bishop to c7
now we have rook to e1 rook to e8 and
Queen to see one now 92 h5 preparing to
bring them right over to f4 we have g3
across him doesn't allow it
g6 kicking tonight away from f5 night to
h6 check King to g7 and here comes the
the 23rd move Knight to g5 a very nice
idea of course everyone sees that King
captures on h6 is basically suicide if
you do this then at night captures here
the night will cover g7 and also there's
a discovered check from the bishop and
black is completely lost here after g5
Bishop captures King g6 now Bishop h6
preparing Queen g5 checkmate you have to
prevent this to guard g5 but now Knight
captures a black is down a piece and his
king is in g6 this is this is terrible
so after Knight g5 wheeler seemed to
plate Knight captures we have
Bishop captures and d5 now he captures
the Bishop captures and Knight to g4
we have Bishop to f3 and here Carlson
plays Bishop to f6 check and this is a
very nice move but the problem is after
this Bishop to f6 move Carson had only 5
minutes on the clock so this is the
first game the last game of the
tournament but the first game in this
tournament where Carson is in time
trouble the problem is if you capture it
with knife captures in f6 Queen to h6
check is coming King to h8 and then of
course Knight captures and f6 and there
is no defense against Queen captures on
h7 with checkmate so after Bishop to
have six widow of course of course we
want King to g8 but still Crossin has
only 5 minutes on the clock
and now he has to figure out a plan
Knight to h6 check only move King to f8
and now Queen to e3 cross in place the
strongest move well as many times
recommended by the engine but the
problem is after cross and plate Queen
to is removed he only had one minute on
the clock and this is the reason I mean
it's the first game Carson was in time
trouble and he spent more time than
usual on moves he would usually make
because this game is is so important he
has to really play this game to the best
of his abilities if he wants to become
Challenger for the World Chess
Championship so ok Bishop back to b7 and
now Bishop to h4 you can't Queen
captures on c5 which check doesn't
really do anything after Bishop to d6
blocking there's no way to prevent
Knight captures on f6 so we're just
gonna lose the bishop there so Electra
Bishop to b7 Bishop to H for not
allowing Knight captures Bishop Queen to
h3 and now
f3 well you can't really blame Carlsen
for for blocking checkmate with f3 a
stronger move was Bishop to d5 but
Carson had less than a minute on the
clock and such a move there was simply
not enough time to calculate you have to
give up a piece temporarily for this
because here comes Bishop captures and
now Queen captures on c5 with check King
moves attacking the knight
six Queen captures on d5 and now King
characters and h6 doesn't work because
white will win this game if King
captures then comes Queen captures on f7
attacking the rook on e8 and also the
bishop on c7 so after rook to ca
defending only move that will defend
both pieces then comes Queen to East
Queen to e7 preparing Bishop to g5
checkmate once you stop this Queen to a5
then comes Rock the c1 with the threat
of rook captures on c7 and after black
trans this Bishop to b6 not threatening
Queen to have to check mate Queen to
have to check then you win with Bishop
to g5 checked Queen captures king queen
capture screen captures and rook
captures there and it's a knight and
Bishop against the rook but cousin will
also be up two points so perhaps not
winning for white but definitely better
for white so yeah
Bishop to d5 definitely a better
defended defending resource but Carson
is less than a minute on the clock so f3
we have Knight to f4 now against a very
nice move by Svidler
again threatening checkmate on g2 Costin
captures that G captures on f4 Queen
captures on h4 now as the pawn is no
longer defending the bishop and Knight
captures on f7 grabbing a very nice pawn
Bishop captures on f3 of course you
cannot capture the bishop because Queen
captures rook on e1 so Queen to f2
offering a trade of Queens but now Queen
g4 check Queen g3 blocking and now pawn
captures on f4 simply grabbing another
pawn we have rook capture screen
captures and Queen captures in g4 Bishop
captures in g4 Knight to g5 h6
kicking away the night Knight back to f7
and now h5 knife to h6 attacking the
bishop and Bishop to D 1 this is move 40
both cost and hence Fielder made their
40th move so tank-tank control has been
reached and now Carson is no longer in
time trouble but sweedler is up upon and
he does have the bishop pair and a
better position and this position is
winning 4 black and when black is you
know maneuvered by by a player of
sealers caliber then it's a winning
position regard
of who he's playing against King to have
to was played and now comes f3 h3 rush
up to f4 we have knife to f7 g5 now
simply preparing to push G for a king to
e1 and now g4 of course the bishop on d1
is is out of the questions because
simply g3 King G 1 G 2 if the King walks
Bishop to e3 or Bishop to h2 but this is
maybe like force the Queen comes into
the game it's all over for white so
after g4 h captures on g4 pawn captures
with King capture son d1 g3 now comes
King g1 g2 King f2 and after Bishop to
h2 the same variation we basically just
shown and at the game and it was in this
position that Magnus Carlsen resigned
the game without without hoping for a
miracle because it was it would be
simply ridiculous but yeah he correctly
resigned and the funny thing is there
will be a press conference after this
game and there will be a link in the
description below feel free to check out
there is an interview with both wheeler
and Carson and by the time this game
ended Kramnik game against the bunch was
still going on so the only thing that
could help Carlsen win this candidates
tournament is if Kramnik loses his game
against the bottom so the only the only
player in the world who can help
Magnus cos and become a challenger to
Vishwanathan Anand is none other than
vastly one but for that we will have to
check out another video that will be the
final video in in the 2013 candidate
series and we're gonna check out what
happens in the game what Mitt Romney
versus vastly von Schuch and it's
interesting before that game even shook
versus Kramnik even shook said in an
interview after round 13 that he doesn't
really care about his game against
chronic it doesn't really affect the
standings the tournament nothing that
you know it'd be better if he just
focuses on his next tournament so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank ya ganvie boor of a
reindeer not Louis Agathon hello
Jonathan neighbor John Abraham and the
guy Chen for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check though my
previous videos here are think'll for
watching and I will see you soon
tomorrow probably with the fourth round
of the Norway Chess Championship but
prior to that I will try to upload the
final game of the 2013 candidates
tournament thank you all and I'll see
you soon I'm going to get that craft
beer now